[Music]
why don't we trust the medical
establishment we don't trust the medical
establishment because they were wrong
about covid we don't trust the medical
establishment because they keep lying to
us there's even a more basic reason and
this is beyond covid it's it's beyond
the vaccines it actually has to do with
the topic du jour that we can never we
always have to be talking about all the
time
in our culture for some reason and that
is transgenderism
transgenderism is a big part of the
reason why i don't trust the medical
community and the experts and the
healthcare system
it is i don't i don't trust doctors who
are affiliated with certain hospitals
and medical groups if those hospitals
and medical groups will perform gender
affirming surgeries and interventions
because i think huh
you don't even know that a man is not a
woman how can i trust your views on any
any other aspect of medicine
you you quacks are going in and pumping
little kids full of cross-sex hormones
and puberty blockers and chopping up
their bodies
why would i trust you about anything
else
regardless of what you think about the
vaccines and the virus and
and all the rest of it if you if the if
the modern medical geniuses don't know
the difference between boys and girls i
just don't trust them i trust my plumber
on basic questions of medicine more than
i trust the modern medical establishment
now there is something we can do about
that
the the libs and the experts and the
technocrats they always try to bully us
and they say you don't know anything
about transgenderism you don't know
anything about medicine you don't you
don't know anything about the science
just listen to the man in the lab code
just listen to whatever dr fauci tells
you just listen to whatever that
hulking dude wearing a dress who is the
assistant secretary of health for
goodness sakes because we're living in a
monty python sketch just listen to
whatever
she tells you she's the expert you don't
know anything and and you think to
yourself uh no
if
if these people are the experts uh give
give me the rubes
give me the know-nothings give me the
idiots because i suspect they know
something more
we can reign in the experts and the
technocrats and the lunatics
we can do that through legislation
we can we can do this through the
political rights whatever political
rights we still have left and some
republican lawmakers are doing just that
this is coming from the republican study
committee congressman jim banks and
representative doug lamalfa
and also tom cotton up on the senate
side they are sponsoring a new piece of
legislation that would allow
individuals to sue
medical providers
for transiting them when they were kids
it's called the protecting minors for
medical malpractice act
this was created in response to the
biden administration pushing transing
the kids and the puberty blockers and
the hormones and the
so-called sex change surgeries for
minors
uh they're they're pushing this law
because they say that that these
kids who grow up and they become adults
and they regret having had these medical
experiments performed on them they need
to be allowed to seek justice in court
at some point on this show i'll have to
read some of the testimonies that are
proliferating all over the internet of
people who regret their transition
even though i don't even want to use
that word transition it makes it sound
so benign
makes it sound so simple oh yes well one
day i'm michael the next day i'm
michelle i transitioned transitioning
involves having your body chopped up and
becoming sterilized permanently usually
and being mutilated and
very often weakening your bones and
giving yourself all sorts of chronic
illnesses potentially giving yourself
osteoporosis
all because of the quackery of these
radicals
and
people need to be given an opportunity
for justice
especially if this happens when you're a
kid if you're a little eight-year-old
kid eight-year-olds in some cases are
being put on these sorts of puberty
blockers
and then being put on cross-sex hormones
and then now the modern transgender
medical associations are encouraging
cross-sex hormones at 14 surgeries at
15. even the full-on surgery that
happens below the belt at 17.
you're a kid you you're below the age of
consent
you're having experiments performed on
you you need to seek
you need to be allowed to seek justice
so how would this happen
sue the doctor sue the medical group sue
all of them i imagine i haven't read the
law i'm not sure that the text of the
law has even been released uh there
there probably has to be some kind of
date before which you are not permitted
to seek
uh
justice i don't know that you're allowed
to do this retroactively in a way it
seems kind of unfair to the doctors who
believe even these psychos even the
people who are chopping up kids some of
them might believe that they're
following the law and doing the right
thing and so
i'm not sure that this law would punish
them that might become problematic but
certainly if you say okay after this
date
if if you as a doctor trans the kids
you're opening yourself up to a huge
legal liability that at the very least
you've got to do that that would be a
huge huge victory
and you'll hear a lot of pushback from
the libs and a lot of pushback from the
doctors and a lot and they'll say this
is terrible you're stopping care you're
bullying doctors you're bullying the
experts and threatening them and
stopping them from performing the
surgeries and the interventions that are
technically legal today and you say yep
you're damn right we are you're right we
are going to use
any
legal means necessary
to stop this
because the reality of it is so
intolerable and so barbaric that no
civilized society should do it ever i'm
glad you like that clip now you know
what you got to do hold up wait no don't
don't move on to the next video you've
got to
subscribe ring that bell ding dong like
let's do it we're coming up on a million
subscribers everybody by the way thank
you for subscribing if you haven't yet
do it send it to your friends we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]